I write very fast and I write in great
volume a big and fast is really the way
I write I write mostly because I want to
get to through the arc as fast as
possible i don't like insecurities and i
don't like surprises and i don't like
not knowing so I i really say in writing
a short story i'll try to get the end as
fast as possible and then i'll spend the
next few months for the next few years
editing um I editing he's a big part of
my process right 75% of it but you know
the novel was written about seven months
first draft he was very fast and I
didn't write everyday those seven months
either I would have these relentless
weekends that I would just write from
you know six a.m. on a saturday morning
till you know 2 a.m. on a monday morning
so I would you know and then it took
another two and a half years to edit
that novel but but fast and big
definitely is something that I believe
in and is necessary for me I'd love to
be one of those writers who Labor's over
every sentence and just goes one
sentence at a time but that's not really
my nature I believe life is short and
let's try to get it out there and just
keep going and not take the whole
process too seriously there's so much
talk among writers about the Holy
experience of writing and the sacredness
of the art but that that's very
intimidating and that's very it's a
teacher I don't like to tell my students
to think that way it's not really going
to send save the world at the end of the
day if you if you want to help people go
out to soup kitchens go out you know
work one-on-one with the homeless and
the truly disenfranchised in the world
but go there and physically do it
writing a book is not going to feed
anyone at the end of the day so I try
not to you know
that posturing into it and I also don't
believe in writing every day I think
that's what creates writer's block the
feeling that you must write every day
there's then then i would think eight
out of ten days you're going to feel
like a very bad writer and I don't have
time for that I want to write when I
when I actually feel good about what I
have to write and so that might just be
a couple times a week it might be for
like a month non-stop but I've never put
that pressure on myself I've never been
one to read the advice of other writers
or or to play by those sort of rules the
sort of John Gardner school of you know
how to be a writer and how to think of
the whole process I'm sort of in the you
know I'm a naturally nervous person so
I'd like to cut down on as much anxiety
as possible
I work you know the material that I have
the very raw material is awfully raw I
mean it's you know sometimes my
sentences don't have period sometimes
there's fragments sometimes every word
is misspelled and a jumbled mess and
there may be four adjectives when I only
need one so I have to really go sentence
by sentence and take the the rock and
chisel at it and get you know what for
some would be their first attempt normal
sentence out of it so it's it's pretty
brutal but knowing that I have the whole
arc I have a beginning middle and end
really becomes encouraging because then
I can look at them my new ship but if I
if I don't have the macrocosm I can't
look at the micro there's there's no way
so I really have to actually go back and
write sentences literally